got a flow facts for you thanksgiving  edition it's not how many calories we  consume is it no but that's a good idea  no don't tell us that we'll save that  for later okay all right flow facts  only male turkeys actually gobble female  turkeys do the cackling actually know  that yeah i think i have an  ex-girlfriend that tackles  um black friday is said to be the  busiest day of the year for plumbers  with probably good reason well a lot of  the grease folks yes let's not think  about the other stuff but yeah my  like uncle sal eating too much and going  to the restroom yeah we'll put this on  social media for you to share with your  friends and family a lot of people are  asking for more flow facts so we're  putting them on there for you but